[Music]
welcome back to after record where we
talk about
whatever we want
and today i want to talk about how it's
unfair
that i had to diet when other people
don't
why do you need a diet you look perfect
you're a bad [ __ ] bro
cool yes thank you but it means nothing
when it comes from you
yes i sucked it in
i sucked it in i know what you mean
though because there are some people
that can eat popeye chicken sandwiches
all day
and they're [ __ ] jack still like who
not but they're miserable no because my
friend alex is pretty happy and he's so
jacked
and all he did was he was eating fast
food all day and he goes
i decided to cut out fast food and when
i wake up i do 100 sit-ups 100 push-ups
and 100
[ __ ] body squats yeah he's doing 100
because he's not [ __ ] anybody
who's who's alex who's my business
partner
he's ripped that's fake jax i'm talking
about real jack dude
not fake jack he's genetic jack so like
real jacked is like you're big and
you're lean
yeah okay oh yeah he's just bruce lee
yeah if you're small and lean that's
that's fake like
fight club doesn't count yeah no
that's good lighting though bro is that
like a big girl with big tits it's not
fair
yes okay so the skinny guy with the abs
is not
nope you didn't work for you not earned
not fair
if we're gonna talk about elliot page
right she came he came sorry
excuse me he came out with his picture
with his abs out
but like his arms were like hella skinny
he got abs
which is nice but he's good but what
really matters to the girls
he got it he gotta get the the pythons
the six-pack
the [ __ ] you gotta get the delts so you
gotta get the traps you know what i mean
the neck he doesn't need too much if he
starts strength training and starts
lifting a little bit
he's like that much better what if he
wants that like artsy
like actor body do you know i mean like
skinny lanky like pete davidson
that's fine what if he's going for the
nightmare before christmas look
yeah yeah yeah the jack skellington you
know
yeah and that's fine that's totally fine
but that's not what bar's talking about
i got
fat you didn't get fat bro did you see
his stomach
nah that's not fat you're like this
weird
like in between like not fat it's called
dad bod
no dead body is just flabby like you're
still like you're stuck i'm bloated
no you're still like tight you know what
i mean like you still have like that dog
fit like that dog tight not like the cat
that's a lot from a gym owner
you [ __ ] just said that doesn't mean
[ __ ] for me
i'm not getting any compliments so i'll
take the last the least
wanted one more specific and that's why
he was like
oh he was he appreciated it okay
it's still not hard enough you guys ever
feel that far
when you flex hard and then you go it's
not hard enough i know i can go harder
like you want your must your muscles to
feel like it's bulging like you feel
like you're not
[ __ ] flexing the right place hard
enough always take some beetroot powder
beetroot what does that do dilator
you'll get a crazy pump because some of
the air you know like when you're
[ __ ] got a boner and you're flexing
like
and your eyes are popping like like that
right is that when you make it like
bounce
they'll bounce yeah and that skin
doesn't get a rip yeah
[Applause]
i love it i love it your dick is a
[ __ ] baby mole trying to get up
it's a mold waiting to happen yeah so i
i was watching like bodybuilders and
like they do the the poses they practice
the poses right
and then the angles and all that yeah
yeah and they can isolate these flexes
but
since you know like i didn't start
athleticism until 35
i was like you're how old i'm 37 so like
i started two years ago and then so like
i was trying to do the same thing and i
noticed i can't isol
my mind like muscle connection yeah i'm
like trying to flex like my arm
and just my wrist is going like this and
i'm like why can't i do it
yeah it takes practice it's really hard
for us that's crazy you know like how
like you know arnold does the the
isolation the bodybuilders like on mr
olympia they're still because like
posing is such a part of the routine
when they're doing like their [ __ ] like
they can
go like every single forearm
they can do all that [ __ ] that's what
i'm saying they had like control every
single fiber like their
muscle condition is crazy damn
they some some bodybuilders say that
like the posing part is actually harder
than the actual training sometimes like
it's more taxing because you need
mobility too
all those big [ __ ] they all of
them can pretty much go like this far
away from the splits
because because one of the biggest
basically dancers yeah because one of
the poses you have to be like
where like this it's like you you have
to have take your shirt off and show
them
there's no dude i don't have i don't
even have bodybuilder mobility they're
actually their mobility is actually
really insane did you use to practice
this one
i don't even know i could [ __ ] around
and do it because i don't i don't see it
because i do it as a comedian i don't
know
i don't know the actual do it as a
comedian go
worth it i don't know i don't know the
real ones
i like it when tycho flexes because he
looks like he's about to pop a vein
every time he's just he's just squeezing
a turn
in the face well no he's into fitness
right now it's really
interesting because we've never like
instilled or tried to push him in that
direction
but he'll like he'll be like hold on i
gotta exercise like before we can do
anything and then he'll start doing
like burpees that's so funny and then
he'll get on the coffee table and then
his feet are on the couch so there's
like a gap in there and he's like doing
push-ups i'm like all right cool dude
because he watches you guys
you guys work out you didn't push him
but you just do it every day so he wants
to do it too
and he's like he sees this part of you
guys routine and he's like i have to
incorporate into my routine so my
parents are jacked i gotta watch paw
patrol and i gotta do some burpees
it's a normal routine yeah i feel like
that's the best way to get people into
[ __ ] is like not even tell them but just
start having fun with it and they're
like
man i wanna do that [ __ ] too yeah what's
happened with my wife she
she hated working out because you kept
telling her to do it yeah and then i
stopped i stopped giving her [ __ ] i was
like and then
the more i went she was like hey i want
to start working out too and then i
would say
no there's the asian guy
no i'm just kidding that up i would take
her with me and she goes lifts with me
you're not even ready to work out with
me right now
yeah so that's what i tell her now when
we start working out it's all good
and it's just because i'm like all right
i'm not gonna give her [ __ ] one time
when she was in college she goes i to
look for a self-defense
instructor were you like
i was like i was like do you know what i
do for a living like i coach people
we don't respect the freaking guys we're
with though you know what i mean
why why does that happen like yeah
because we didn't because the stupid
side of you were like
you're gonna teach me you have a [ __ ]
plastic knife that you pick your nose
with she's so good
she saw me almost pooped my pants one
time on the way home for a restaurant
and that's why she didn't take you
she's like nah bro i'm not gonna take
lessons from this [ __ ] guy yeah
you're gonna teach me how to fight like
get out of here dude while you [ __ ]
yourself you almost pooped your pants
like what are you talking about
so so in order for girls to give us the
full respect
we have to be [ __ ] perfect that's
that's what that is
no just don't be dumb i feel like even
if you were perfect your significant
other won't listen to you
i think it's the girl they got internal
work they got to do
you got to do that it's him it's not out
of them it's
the thing you know it's that switch
right the thing about yeah
yeah cause think about you think
michelle obama takes obama seriously
probably because she saw him do stupid
[ __ ] this guy runs the country
when you're the president okay okay
you don't know [ __ ] obama i know what
you're saying
[ __ ] stupid no because it does take
everyone else's
like i will say something about fitness
whatever
and she'll be like okay like it will go
over her head yep
and then somebody will be talking about
the exact same topic yeah but it's just
not me
that's all that's to see what katie
hearn said yeah
literally you guys do the same [ __ ] to
us we'll be saying the same [ __ ]
it's a relationship thing bro like bro
we just told you that like i
said literally the same thing but
because nick said it now it's valid and
he's like
uh he just explained it new for it i'm
like it is weird like that my
uh one of our faculty members in this
like prem red program i was in
so he went to john hopkins for medical
school so it's like one of the top
medical schools ever
and he's been trying to tell his dad
that chocolate affects diabetes
for [ __ ] ages and then he says dad
never listens
and then finally his dad went to go see
a doctor and he came back and then he
was like hey did you know chocolate
[ __ ] with your diabetes he goes oh my
god i'm a [ __ ]
doctor you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] i'm like
damn
just happy like when you get everybody
yeah when you get too comfortable family
and family just
they're just not credible anymore yeah
everyone's just like i have a feeling
people forget that they change
yeah they change their mind or they they
they're finally able to hear it
and i go oh yeah chocolate and diabetes
that makes a lot of [ __ ] sense
and then they like you gotta be that
forgetful
to tell the person that told you yeah as
if it's new information yeah
that's so true right yeah because they
they that means they they don't even
remember hearing it
when they did some people are not ready
to hear things yeah so they're ready to
hear things
across the board yeah that was the
smartest [ __ ] you've ever said this guy
tells me
all the times he's like hey social media
is important i'm like yeah yeah okay
dude
and then three weeks later i'll be like
hey bart you know i post this on
instagram and i got clients
it's crazy it was great and he's like
whoa and he's like yeah i've been
telling you that [ __ ]
[ __ ] piece of trash that's so magical
yeah
so there's a correlation i think not
confirmed
don't believe everything he says i don't
today's video is brought to you by
upstart it's crypto season
everyone's talking about crypto man i
got a crypto story for you guys because
man last bull run around 2017
we all [ __ ] went hard yeah we did we
went
in and um i put myself in a certain hole
you know i bought a lot of crypto it
pumped
and then it dumped hard and it crashed
during that time i thought it was going
to recover
but it turned into next year and guess
what i got hit with some taxes
and then i didn't have any money i had a
lot of money that i had that i owed to
the government and i said oh my god
how am i going to come up with more
money i don't i don't know
yeah your actual liquid cash is tied up
in investments
that's why i wish i knew about something
like upstart at the time because i went
and got a personal loan
and with upstart it only takes about
five minutes to even check
if you're qualified and what's cool is
they give you up to like
fifty thousand dollars and then they go
beyond just your credit score
so they check you know other things like
your education
i have a bachelor's degree so i'm hoping
that that would have been okay because
it shows that i'm responsible
um do i have a job yes i do they check
things like that
do you have income all these other
things that kind of
add to your credibleness and at the time
i really need something
and i think upstart would have been a
much better choice yeah and if
you're like joe and you're in a pinch
and you need a loan or if you just have
a great business idea and you need a
loan there's many reasons why you would
need
extra money upstart is a great option
because like joe
said it's not just based off your credit
score it could be based on your credit
score your income your
college education and any other
information you put on the loan
application but it's great to check it
out
because you can see if it's a lower
percentage rate than is offered
on your credit card or any other loan
just go to upstart.com
off the record to give it a try and see
what percentage you're offered and it's
only five minutes that's
upstart.com off the record maybe post
another photo
yeah we'll see what happens of me just
like petting my dog
i do i pet my dog and i don't have more
clients it doesn't work
this guy's full of [ __ ] bro your social
media advice
doesn't work doesn't it what does he
know he doesn't know anything i don't
know anything man no i guess like
because if a girl is telling you
anything about other than sandwich
making it's difficult to realize
it's difficult to listen it's hard you
know
because you know she's an expert on like
bacon before the lettuce before okay and
then you're just like thank you
i'll do that next time yeah but why are
you stepping out of your lines dude yeah
why are you so out of line right now
he's trying to tell you anything else
aside from that it's like
what are you a credibility what if i was
telling you like like the way to lose
weight when you get the white bread and
then you
have to smother it with mayo is you have
to stop eating you fat [ __ ] and then
you put that i'm like i can't hear it
better when there's a penis inside of
your mouth
i don't understand this it's like a you
know it's like a man's telescope you
know when you speak or the microphone if
you speak into the dick yeah
we get it more i understand what you're
saying
i'll take out the trash i'll take out
the challenge i'll put the toilet seat
up
close all the cabinets i swear it works
it really works the trick is to stop
before they come so they get blue balls
if they don't do the thing
or you could just like pull it out with
your teeth like that who's really in
control now
who's really i am because i'm like if
you don't make me i'm gonna make myself
come
i could do it myself
i think cat has it figured out is you
start the day right before we
die and then we you tell us everything
to do
and then at the end it's like you get
your reward but until you have to do
everything
wow just keep edging them that's what it
is
damn and then you become a master of
kumasutra you know
kuma sutra what the [ __ ] is kuma's
suicidal
evil
yeah i don't know that you [ __ ] hood
version
[Laughter]
a lot more gang signs yeah kuma is like
you say it
comma comma
it with somebody's sex culture right now
man yeah that's my bad well actually
it's so ancient i don't think anybody
remembers
do you think that [ __ ] really works like
some of the positions
man that [ __ ] looks tiring bro that [ __ ]
looks like it looks unpractical bro
what's the point of kamasutra i think
it's like it's a spirituality
yeah spiritually like the way you do it
at different like entangled lakes it's
supposed to be like
more connected or something that means
we feel really connected
and you guys did the kamasutra what's
your favorite no we get pretty tangled
though
what's your favorite position kuma sutra
style puma
when his legs are behind his back and
i'm like [ __ ] fingering his ass
when you're holding him and his legs are
wrapped around you exactly yeah where's
your mobility show us
going yeah and then his fingers i mean
his butthole's exposed and i'm like [ __ ]
yeah
you're putting your nose in it bart's in
a pretzel no never know yeah
i overstepped he puts he puts his finger
on my butt
into his mouth and he comes in his mouth
she's sucking it and then he's like
about to come okay
she sprays it back at his face it's like
the bellagio
[Laughter]
that's tight bro welcome to splash we'll
teach you something welcome to the
splash zone dude you don't do that dude
nah you're so boring i'm [ __ ] whack
man dude you're a grandpa
i'm a yeah i told you i'm a square i got
to step it up yeah
that's just how you know they've been
married for a long time i think the
longer you're married
the more you come on yourself space
you make it okay the longer you're with
someone eventually i feel like the guy
gets into butt stuff really i'm already
i'm already into it and i'm not even in
a relationship good for you you're just
like
leagues ahead of the game i don't want
he's gonna slow down
he's gonna get bored he's gonna start
doing weird [ __ ] no i'm going i'm
digressing
i just i just like missionary now
missionary plane
do you pull your underwear down or no i
put it through the hole good for you
i went the other way i went i went i
went so nasty that now
like just soft core works you're like
benjamin button now you're going
backwards
let's just let's just rub on each other
and make out and i'll [ __ ] just draw
over the pants stuff yeah yeah what does
that call dry humping
right now yeah that should be the next
hit dog this is a hit back in the day i
hire a older hooker just to pretend to
be my mom who's like
checking in on me and [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
people don't talk about that it's like
um so me and my girl gonna be watching
some netflix can you like
check in randomly and then we have to
like oh [ __ ] we're not doing nothing
yeah
yeah that's that's fun people like being
caught in the act
where are you gonna what at what age are
you gonna go where now you're all your
homies and you guys are just jacking off
but not trying to watch each other
after after this video you're
so virgin to the point where you're not
even experimenting with girls
no you're just like when i get a vhs
and then we'd be like hey guys i got it
and then bart's like we got it and then
casey's like yeah
you got a portal finally i've never seen
a titty before
and we all [ __ ] have a sleepover yeah
and then you're like i found it dude is
that 43
probably 53. okay yeah yeah yeah that's
what was fun again and by the time i'm
60
i'm just getting off on holding hands
yeah
yo she let me hold her hand dude huh or
you have the ripped playboy
just the one just one thing victoria's
secret catalog yeah
yeah that's the new [ __ ] dude the
jcpenney catalogues no uh victory signal
victoria's secret yeah
there's just one leg jc penny
don't sleep on that nah i like the like
the the blouses bro
it is harder when it's affordable yeah
yeah yeah yeah when it's just like
outward
out outerwear like patagonia or
something
[Applause]
yeah i feel like all these old people in
the east coast like hiking with those
clothes
yeah and they're but their idea of hiki
just walking on a dirt road
with six yeah with a steak
and they got like a chocolate lab or
something yeah they always have a
chocolate
a gnarly beard yeah yeah bart wants to
get a lab and i'm so against the lab
we've been seeing a ton of labs in our
neighborhood
because then those people have and i
don't want to be those i want a golden
retriever
what people do you want to be what type
of person cute crazy [ __ ] young
people
i want to be young there's labs with
they're cute though there's like
i like uh the black labs because then
you can't even see where the eyeballs
are or the nose
okay jokes aside i actually really like
weird-looking dogs
like what like a hairless chihuahua no
what about a pug
no so i want like a great dane but i
want like the black and white one like a
cow
[ __ ] big one like a dalmatian great
thing
or like a poodle like i like the rare
like you're like
you're like a british your british
aristocrat there's like a british
aristocrat like something weird
yeah both of those are british dogs yeah
i would say
weird would be like an afghan hound they
look like that big greyhound
yeah they look like um they look like
greyhounds so imagine a greyhound
but then they have long like long like
dragons yeah
okay
you look like a mop do you have to get
your dog's hair perm then
i don't know you might need conditioner
every time i think you have to bro
[ __ ] it but we also don't want long hair
though because we had german shepherds
and they shed like crazy yeah we're
trying to find a dog that has good
like easy upkeep like dobermans are sick
as [ __ ] too i just can't
clip there i just i'm they look cute
without the cliff the ears they look
like
the floppy ears i want them to look like
they're gonna kill you then once you get
a pit bull
i want to dude pits are so cute it's a
good time they look like fat
babies they're such good dogs too
they're really good except like
sometimes they want to kill other dogs
really badly like other than that though
bro they're such
sweet little pups bro i love god i want
to get a pit what are you going to get
one
we have like four dogs here we can do
you really i've never seen you
you never talk about your dog well
they're always at my parents house right
yeah and my wife's parents house
so we feel bad if we get another dog why
are they always somewhere else
because they're our parent there are
families dogs so this you don't have
[ __ ] but they're
definitely no bro that's not how it
works it's whatever's in your [ __ ]
premise
all right on my premises i have zero
dogs then you don't have them you don't
have to but in my
family bro i got dogs bro yeah i got
dogs
i love my dogs i love all my dogs so
much that they don't even [ __ ] live
with you
we see them like we see them a couple
like four times a week there's seven
days i just lied i just
whatever dude don't be a [ __ ] bummer
yeah i think i want i want a big dog
how big i want i think i'd like a pit
i think i'm leaning towards it you get
it but i think we're going to do it
because we have four dogs that don't
live with us i want a golden retriever
yeah gorgeous another kid and a toe
sauce
i wanted to get a um what are they
called
not belvedere what the [ __ ] say bernard
oh yeah beethoven yeah i wanted to get a
saint bernard
but then i looked it up on my how are
they you know i know vegas is very it's
too high
yeah i like googled it and they can't
get a jewelry dog they said saint
bernards
aren't good in the hot weather something
can't do massive so either then
they drool too much who no mastiffs yeah
they got those flappy mouths
slobber is pretty crazy though that's
that's that's difficult to upkeep
and then they do you do that thing and
it's like
can't do it are you guys gonna get a dog
soon is that you guys have a timeline on
it no
maybe next year
[Music]
you